[Music]
people all across this great nation are
in pain
they have hard lives are you still sore
i can't work here no more it'll be all
right
and we
have the cure
this new miracle drug
oxyconta
you will be the largest sales force in
pharmaceutical history make your doctors
feel special take them to expensive
dinners bribe the receptionist with a
mani-pedi whatever it takes to win their
trust
your most effective talking point are
these magic words
less than one percent of people get
addicted to oxycontin that's not
possible
i can't live like this anymore i started
on this call on a miracle drug they only
take two a day
i think i can make this the biggest drug
in the world
i think maybe that medicine might be
just a tad more addictive than you said
that's not what we're hearing
something is happening here
there might be a unique situation
brewing
a pharma company is lying about their
medication
we have to go after the makers of
oxycontin
my patients trusted me i can't believe
how many of them are good now
we're going to do everything in our
power to make sure justice is served
we're going to cure the world
of its pain
[Music]
you